شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون معكم في
تغطيه للاوضاع الدراماتيكيه في السودان في
اخر التطورات اتهم الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع باستخدام اسلوب القصف العشوائي في
وقت تشهد مناطق وفي الخرطوم قصفا نفذه
الجيش بطائرات مقاتله اما الوضع في اقليم
دارفور فبات اكثر تعقيدا حيث يحتدم القتال
غرب البلاد الوضع الصحي باتن بكارثه وسط
تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه حيث سقط المزيد من
القتلى وواصل المدنيون الفرار من مناطق
الاقتتال بينما دعت الصحه العالميه اطراف
النزاع الى اخلاء المرافق الصحيه فورا
[موسيقى]
كما ترون انه مسجد بدايه السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان من
قوه الانفجار وجينا ما عندنا شيء قنابل
ولا نشربه
خلاص اصبحنا تعبانين
سيد البرهان والسيد حميد
نسبه لتعب الشعبي وللمعاناه التي عانها
الشعب السوداني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومع استمرار المواجهات وصف الجيش السوداني
الموقف العسكري داخل وخارج الخرطوم
بالمستقر للغايه واضاف الجيش ان الوضع ليس
كذلك في ولايه غربي دارفور التي شهدت
صراعا قبليا يجري على او تجري معالجته
بواسطه السلطات المحليه
الجيش اضاف ان قوته متماسكه وتؤدي دورها
في دحر التمرد في كل الاتجاهات وان الايام
المقبله ستشهد انفراجا كبيرا على الارض
على حد وصف البيان كما اشار الجيش الى ان
قوات الدعم السريع حاولت قصف قياده
المنطقه المركزيه نهار امس لكن قوات الجيش
تصدت لهم وكبدتهم خسائر كبيره
بيان الجيش اكد السيطره على معظم الولايات
الا انه وصف الوضع بالخرطوم بالمعقد بسبب
حشد قوات الدعم السريع لمعظم عناصرها هناك
[موسيقى]
مبروك
الله مبروك مبروك
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
بشن هجوم ضد قواتها في معسكر بمنطقه كفوري
في الخرطوم بحري بالطيران والمدفعيه وقالت
في بيانها انه تم التصدي للهجوم والسيطره
على اعتاد عسكري وقالت ايضا ان الجيش واصل
شن هجمات على معسكرات رغم الهدنه
الانسانيه
من جانبه افاد مراسل العربيه بان سلاح
الطيران التابع للجيش السوداني شن غارات
جويه استهدفت مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
المتواجده في محيط القياده العامه كما
اشار الى استهداف طيران الجيش لقوات الدعم
السريع المتواجده في منطقه صالحه ام درمان
هذا فيما افاد مراسل العربيه ايضا عن سماع
يدويه اطلاق مضادات ارضيه تابعه للدعم
السريع في محيط القياده العامه بالخرطوم
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه المعلنه دعت روسيا
اطراف النزاع الى ضبط النفس
الناطقه باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخاروره دعت الى اتخاذ خطوات عاجله
لوقف اطلاق النار وقالت ان الاحداث
الماساويه التي يشهدها السودان تثير قلق
موسكو التي تتخذ كافه الاجراءات اللازمه
لضمان سلامه رعاياها في السودان وامكانيه
تنفيذ اجراءات الاجلاء
[تصفيق]
هذا وناشد مواطن سوداني طرفي الصراع لوقف
الحرب والاقتتال والعوده الى طاوله الحوار
اناشد السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبي انني
يوقف الحرب يا جماعه نسبه لتعب الشعبي
وللمعاناه التي عاناها الشعب السوداني
الذي لم يستحق هذه المعاناه يا جماعه
ارجوكم راضيه في طاوله بتاعه حوار وكل
خلافات كل لان خلافاتكم شخصيه يا جماعه
يا جماعه ربنا ده سبحانه وتعالى هيحاسبكم
على ما فعلتوه في الدنيا وفي الاخره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معي من ام درمان الاهلي مزيد من المتابعه
الصحفي شهد نادر شهدي اهلا وسهلا بك الى
هذه التغطيه مجددا اخر التطورات الميدانيه
وابرز مشاهداتك في الساعات القليله
الماضيه
مرحبا ما يزال الطيران العسكري يحلق في
سماء درمان سماع متقطع لذوي المضادات
الارضيه في عده اتجاهات من الجنوب ومن شرق
مدينه ام درمان شهود عيانه فادوا بان
منطقه الخرطوم بحري كذلك تشهد امنا وشات
في بعض المناطق وكذلك منطقه الخرطوم
هذا هو في اليوم وهذا هو مجمل مشهد اليوم
الثالث للهدنه المعلنه مع بين الجيش
والدعم السريع التي لم تخلو من خلقات على
مدى ايامها الله الثلاثاء ولكن في المجمل
تكاد تكون هذه الهدنه هي افضل بكثير من
سابقاتها اليوم حركه ملحوظه وينبضت طفيفه
للمواطنين الذين اضطروا الى الخروج من
داخل الاحياء الى خارجها بحثا عن
احتياجاتهم
الاساسيه اليوم بحسب شهود عيان حاولت
مجموعات الهجوم مع مجموعات نحو مسلح
الهجوم على سوق ام درمان ولكن لم تستطع
الدخول اليه الاحياء المجاوره
السوق اتصدق اتصدت لها سكان الاحياء
المجاوره لسوق ام درمان مع تصدد لهذه
المجموعات ومنعتها من التوكل لممارسه
اعمال النهب التي تنتشر بشكل كبير في خلال
الايام الذي انتشرت خلال بشكل كبير خلال
الايام
الماضيه في ظل انشقاق الطرفي الصراع
بالاقتال وقياب للشرطه حتى هذه اللحظه
التي يتحدث فيها معك طيب
شهدي الجيش في بيانه اليوم قال ان الوضع
مستقر تماما داخل وخارج الخرطوم باستثناء
دارفور هل يمكنك تاكيد ذلك ام لا يعني
الوضع غير مستقر
كما قلت بان اليوم هناك حاله حاله عفوا
حاله الهدوء افضل من
خلال هذه الهدنه افضل من
مواطنين المواطنين يستطيعوا ان يخرجوا
ولكن على المجمل هناك اصوات مضادات ارضيه
تسمع بين الفينه والاخرى من عده اتجاهات
خصوصا هذه هذه الاصوات كسرت بشده وذويها
ازداد بشكل كبير خلال ساعات ليلى ليلى امس
وبد ملحوظه في سماع مدينه
كما تعلم ولايات دارفور تحديدا الولايات
غربي دارفور وحاضرتها مدينه الجنينه تشهد
اشتباكات اخذت طابع قبلي المدينه تعيش في
فوضى عارمه منذ ليله امس الاول
غياب
تامنيه عمليات النهب لسوق المدينه
ومنشاتها الحيويه كالمؤسسات وخلافه هي
تعيش في فوضى فوضى فوضى بمعنى بكل ما
تحميله هذه هذه الكلمه اليوم
نشرت تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
صورا لما قالوا انه بعض قوات الحركات
المنضويه
حمايه المدنيين بانها ستنزل الى الشوارع
هناك في مدينه
الجنينه لتوفير الحمايه
للمدنيين طيب شهودي هل هنالك مؤشرات على
امكانيه تمديد الهدنه
بحسب بيان القوات المسلحه بالامس بان
القائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان قد وافق
على
مبدئيا على المبادره التي تسلمها من منظمه
الايجارات والتي تقضي بتمديد الهدنه ولكن
بيان الخارجيه السودانيه اليوم اعلن بانه
لا تصاوب مع
الاخر قوات الدعم السريع ووصفها بانها
ووصفها بانها قوات متمرده طيب
هناك ضغوط خارجيه وداخليه
عبر
حسابها واغفر الاقتتال نسبه لدواعي ربما
تكون كارثيه على على على السودانيين عموما
طيب
موقف باقي القوى
السودانيه من مبادره الايراد هل يمكن
القول ان هذه المبادره ستسلق طريقها في
المستقبل ام لا الوضع غامض تماما شهدي
فيما يتعلق بهذه المبادره برقم المواقف
المبدئيه منها
نعم القوس القوى السياسيه السودانيه القوه
الموقعه للاتفاق الايطالي وكذلك مجموعه
الكتله الديمقراطيه عبر بيانات مختلفه
اكدت انها تجري اتصالات داخليه وخارجيه
اخيرها اتصالات اجراها رئيس جيش تحرير
السودان السيد الهادي ادريس وهو ايضا قوه
تحرير السودان الهادي ادريس المجلس
الانتقالي
اعلن انه تلقى اتصالا هاتفيا او تبادل
النظر حول الازمه وما يمكن حلها مع الرئيس
الاوغندي اوري موسيتيني
والاحزاب وقوه خارجيه والدول الخارجيه
ومنظمات دوليه من اجل بحث نزع فتيل الازمه
ووقت عمليه وقت هذا هذا الاختتال
من ام درمان الصحفي السوداني شودي نادر
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
وبالحديث اعزائي المشاهدين عن مبادره
ايجاد من اجل وقف اطلاق النار التي اثير
اثيرت حولها العديد من التساؤلات حول تلك
المبادره وما تتضمنه دعونا نتابع هذا
التقرير
ماذا تضمنت مبادره المنظمه الاقليميه
المعنيه بالتنميه في شرق افريقيا ايجاد
تضمنت مقترحات مقتضبه لحل الازمه في
السودان
نصت على تمديد الهدنه الحاليه التي تنتهي
الخميس لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
ودعوه الطرفين المتحاربين لارسال ممثلين
عنهما او مبعوث عسكري الى جوبا جنوب
السودان لاجراء محادثات بينهما ايجاد طلبت
ارسال مندوبي الطرفين الى جوبا يوم الجمعه
المقبل الساعون للمبادره هم رؤساء جنوب
السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي الجيش اعلن
موافقته المبدئيه على المبادره
وترجيحات بان يكون الفريق شمس الدين كباشي
ممثلا للجيش لا تعليق حتى الان من الدعم
السريع بشان المبادره
ومع استمرار المواجهات وترد الاوضاع
الامنيه في السودان وسط استمراري عمليات
الاجلاء تستمر حركه النزوح الداخلي الى
مناطق بعيده عن مواقع الاشتباكات او الى
دول الجوار حيث يستمر الابلاغ عن نزوح
المدنيين في ولايات الخرطوم والولايه
الشماليه والنيل الازرق وشمال كردفان
وشمال دارفور وغرب دارفور وجنوب دارفور
الى جانب التحركات عبر الحدود الى الدول
المجاوره وقد حذرت الامم المتحده من ان
ربع مليون سوداني قد يكونون في طريقهم
للهرب برا الى الدول المجاوره ومن بين
الدول المجاور للسودان فان اهم التحركات
وفق مفوضيه اللاجئين هي نحو تشاد وجنوب
السودان
المفوضيه اوضحت ان الذين شقوا طريقهم
بانفسهم الى المناطق الحدوديه مع تشاد
يقدر عددهم بنحو عشرين الفا
كما انها تتوقع عبور نحو 45 الف لاجئ
سوداني جديد الى جنوب السودان والى مصر
الجاره الشماليه ذا فقد ذكرت المفوضيه ان
لديها تقارير عن بدء خروج بعض النازحين
الى مصر في حين اعلنت السلطات المصريه ان
الاف الاشخاص من مختلف الجنسيات تمكنوا من
الخروج من السودان الى مصر عبر معبري قسطل
وارجين حيث يتجاوز عددهم العشره الاف شخص
تشتد الازمه هناك وتنفرج في المعابر
والموانئ والمطارات لكن قبل الوصول الى بر
الامان ثم تحديات يجب تخطيها
ولعل الوضع الامني المتردي اخطر تحدي لذا
تشكل الهدن متنفسا للحركه لكن ذلك مرهون
بالتزام طرفي النزاع بوقف اطلاق النار
فمنذ اكثر من عشره ايام اعلن عن اربع هدى
بواسطات دوليه العنوان الابرز لها خروق
وانهيار العائق الثاني في حال تجاوز
الفرينه هشاشه الهدن يتمثل في كلفه التنقل
فثمن تذكره الرحله الى بورتسودان من
الخرطوم في الحافله يصل الى 400 دولار
للشخص الواحد لكن ثمه ازمه اخرى محطات
وقود مغلقه اما الانقطاع الوقود او
الاستهدافها تشهد الاسعار ارتفاعات كبيره
فتكلفه الجالون في السوق السوداء بلغت 50
دولارا اي عشره اضعاف السعر الرسمي
وللتنقل لابد من الدفع هنا مشكله اخرى لا
ولا صرافات اليه والبنوك مغلقه حتى تحويل
الاموال عبر تطبيقات الهواتف لا يعمل
معضله اخرى قذائف وشظايا لم تنفجر قد تكون
في انتظار اصطياد ضحايتها لذا تشدد
المنظمات على تجنب التعامل مع اي منها
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الخيارات المره والصعبه يختار
البعض المخاطره غير ان اخرين يفضلون
البقاء في منازل ستكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر
امنا من مخاطر رحله قد لا تكون محسوبه
العواقب
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ايضا ينضم الي
من الخرطوم مصباح احمد وهو رئيس دائره
الاعلام في حزب الامه القومي والقيادي في
الحريه والتغيير مصباح اهلا وسهلا بك الى
هذه التغطيه لنبدا معك بالاوضاع الامنيه
تحديدا الهدنه الهشه اليوم الثالث عشر من
المواجهات هل تعتقد ان هذه الهدنه الهشه
ستظل صامده وسيتم التمديد لها ام لا
الامور يعني غير واضحه وربما لا تبشر
بالخير
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك يا اخي
الكريم والتحيه للمشاهدي قناه الحدث انت
عبر العربيه يعني الشقيقه الحدث يعني محطه
اخرى بالقرب منا ولكن انت عبر العربيه
سيد مصباح
مصباح احمد هل تسمعني
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع رئيس دائره
الاعلام
في حزب الامه والقياديه في الحريه
والتغيير لا نعود اليه بطبيعه حال فورا
جهوز الاتصال هنالك مشكله منذ بدء
الاقتتال في السودان في خاص موضوع
الاتصالات نعانيها دائما على الهواء
مباشره على كل في اخر تطورات عمليات
الاجلاء التي تنفذها الدول الغربيه من
السودان اعزائي المشاهدين دعا وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفري دع
الرعايه البريطانيين في السودان الى
الالتحاق بالرحلات الجويه دون تاخير مشيرا
الى ان بريطانيا قد لا تكون قادره على
مواصله عمليات الاجلاء عندما ينتهي وقف
اطلاق النار
وقالت لي ان الوقت قد حان لتشريع تلك
الجهود مشيرا الى نجاح بريطانيا في اجلاء
اكثر من 500 شخصا جوا من السودان حتى الان
حان الوقت للتحرك لدينا طائرات والقدرات
ايضا هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لذلك نقول
للناس اذا كنتم تريدون الحصول على دعمنا
للسفر خارج السودان فافعلوا ذلك الان
يمكننا تسهيل خروجكم ربما سيقرر بعض
الاشخاص لاسباب خاصه البقاء حتى عندما يتم
وقف اطلاق النار لكننا نقول هناك رحلات
جويه واذا كنت ترغب في السفر فهذا هو افضل
وقت للقيام بذلك
هذا واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن
تنفيذه عمليات اجلاء جديده مؤكده ان
عمليات الاجلاء شملت مواطنين فرنسيين
وكذلك مواطنين من بريطانيا والولايات
المتحده وكندا واثيوبيا وهولندا وايطاليا
والسويد كما اكدت انها قامت حتى الان
باجلاء
96 شخصا
مع باريس مراسل العربيه فريده لمزيد من
المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع فادي اهلا وسهلا
بك كيف تسير عمليات الاجلاء وكم تبقى من
الرعايه الفرنسيين اذا كان لديك اي
معلومات
اهلا طالب وزاره الدفاع والخارجيه اصدرتها
بيانا مشتركا اليوم قالت فيه ان عدد من تم
اجلائهم حتى الان بلغت 936 شخصا بينهم 200
و14 فرنسيا اخر عمليه اجلاء حصلت يوم امس
حيث قامت الفرقات الفرنسيه لورين باجلاء
398 شخصا من بين هؤلاء خمسه مواطنين
فرنسيين تم اجلائهم من بورسودان هؤلاء
يحملون جنسيات اكثر من 50 دوله بينها
بريطانيا الولايات المتحده ايطاليا
نيوزيلندا المغرب وحتى اشخاص سودانيين
بحسب البيان لا يوجد حتى الان معلومات عن
كم بقي من المواطنين الفرنسيين في السودان
لكن ايضا تم الاعلان عن اجلاء الفريق
الفني لنادي الهلال السوداني لكره القدم
وافراده يحملون الجنسيه الفرنسيه طبعا
عمليات الاجلاء معقده جدا ومحفوفه
بالمخاطر يتولاها نحو 150 جنديا فرنسيا من
القوات الخاصه وعناصر حمايه بالاضافه الى
عناصر من الاستطلاع والدعم اللوجستي
والعاملين في المجال الطبي خلال احدى
عمليات الاجلاء بحسب الرئيس الفرنسي اصيب
جندي فرنسي حالته اصبحت مستقره الان ايضا
مستشار التعاون في السفاره الفرنسيه في
الخرطوم والذي كان من بين من تم اجلائهم
يوم امس قال لحظه نزوله من الطائره التي
حطت في مطار شارلو غول في باريس قال انهم
عاشوا اسبوعا من الفوضى وكان لهم حظ كبير
لتمكنهم من الفرار من مناطق الاشتباك بحسب
وصفه وقال ايضا ان بعض من تم اجلائهم
كانوا مصابين كذلك
فادي سمعنا بعض التقارير من فرنسا عن وجود
قوات خاصه او قوات كوماندوس في السودان
تحديدا بين الخرطوم وبورسودان لتامين
عمليات الاجلاء الى اي مدى هذا الكلام
صحيح ام لا يعني هذه مبالغات لا وجود لمثل
هكذا قوات
هذه القوات موجوده واعلنت عنها وزاره
الدفاع قالت ان نحو 150 من عناصر القوات
الخاصه
متواجدين هناك في السودان لتامين عمليات
الاجلاء
بحسب بيان
لهيئه الاركان الفرنسيه هناك جندي اصيب
واكد هذا الخبر ايضا الرئيس الفرنسي خلال
اجتماع لمجلس الامن القومي يوم الثلاثاء
الماضيه لان هذا الجندي اصيب خلال عمليات
الاجلاء الوزاره لا تفصح عن معلومات اكثر
لكن الخبر بوجود قوات فرنسيه خاصه هذا خبر
صحيح وهو رسمي
فادي بالنسبه الى موضوع امكانيه التمديد
للهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار هل ثم تفاؤل
فرنسي في هذا الخصوص يعني في موقف فرنسي
تحدث عن امكانيه تمديد هذه الهدنه
بعد يعني اثنتين وسبعين ساعه ام لا ما في
كلام عن موضوع الهدنه على الاقل من
الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الكلام الفرنسي حول الهدنه في السودان هو
في اطار التفاؤل والتمني بان يتم تمديدها
لكن لا يوجد معلومات مفصله حول هذه
المساله لا تفصح وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
عن اي اتصالات او عن اي معلومات حول هذه
سوى انها تقول انها متفائله وتتمنى ان يتم
تمديدها ليتم اجراء من تبقى من المواطنين
الاوروبيين او حتى الاشخاص الذين يجب
اجلؤهم من السودان الى مناطق اخرى امنه
وايضا من اجل ان يحظى المدنيون السوداني
في السودان
بفرصه لالتقاط انفاسهم وان يعيشوا بسلام
بعد هذه الاشتباكات فادي هل علقت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه على مبادره الايجاد
ويعني هل ترى انها مشروع للحل ومشروع لوقف
دائم لاطلاق النار ام لا يوجد اي موقف
فرنسي من مبادره الايجاد
لا يوجد حتى الان موقف فرنسي لكن الموقف
العام الذي تعبر عنه وزاره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه والدبلوم الدبلوماسيون الفرنسيون
يقولون انهم يدعمون اي مبادره للتواصل
للحل وجلوس طرفي النزاع على طاوله
المفاوضات من اجل وضع حد لهذه الاشتباكات
لكن لا يوجد معلومات او لا يوجد تصريح
واضح حول انهم يدعمون هذه المبادره ام لا
حتى الان من باريس مراسل العربيه فريده
هوك شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
فادي
وحول عمليات الاجلاء البريطانيه اعزائي
المشاهدين ينضم اليهم جدا الان هيثم حمد
وهو نائب القنصل البريطاني للشؤون
القنصليه سيد هيثم اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه
التغطيه من العربيه اولا كيف تسير عمليات
الاجلاء وفق متابعتك بشكل عام وعمليات
الاجلاء البريطانيه بشكل خاص
والله بشكل عام يعني اولا احنا حابين نشكر
خادم الحرمين الشريفان وسمو ولي العهد
يعني باجلاء
المواطنين
البريطانيين
ويعني هذه عمليه جدا جباره كانت واللي
يعني احنا
بالنسبه للجلاع هي كانت فيها اكيد ترتيبات
جدا جدا جدا يعني ممكن خلينا نقول يعني
متعاقده ولكن ولله الحمد وصلوا الى هنا
البريط وليس البريطانيه يعني
عديد عديد من الجنسيات واحنا حابين نشكر
كل الدوائر الحكوميه الذي
ساهمت في في هذه
العمليه الانسانيه اللي قامت بها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا تم تم تسكين بعض
تم تمكين السكن
لمواطنين
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
لو تعطينا فقط معلومات بالارقام عدد
البريطانيين الذين وصلوا ميناء جده
ككل وعددهم اليوم عدد الذين وصلوا اليوم
وماذا عن باقي الجنسيات الاخرى التي ساهمت
ايضا المملكه المتحده في اجلائهم بمساعده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وصولا الى ميناء
جده
[موسيقى]
عفوا معلش اعيد السؤال مره ثانيه ابرز
معنا هؤلاء يعني عندما تتحدث معهم سواء
الرعايه البريطانيين او من جنسيات مختلفه
ابرز ما عنوه خلال رحله اللجوء وعندما يصل
الى جده كيف تتم متابعه امورهم
ثم ادرى
يعني
متجهين من من العاصمه الى بورسودان ومن
هذه تاخذ منهم يعني طاقه وساعات ساعات
طويله جدا
ومنهم اللي هي امراه حامله والى اخره
والحمد لله يعني احنا الان لما
المتابعه تتم مع السلطات السعوديه
بيخبرونا
بصوره يعني بصوره
وبنفس تايم بخبرونه بوقت كافي انه عارفين
في في
حتكون جاي او الى اخره فيها عده عدد من
الرعايه البريطانيه ونروح نتم استقبالهم
في ميناء جده الاسلامي مع السلطات
السعوديه
من جده نائب القنصل البريطاني لشؤون
القنصليه هيثم محمد شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
وايضا في اخر جهود السعوديه في اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب والعرب من السودان ينضم
الي من القاعده الجويه في جده مراسل
العربيه نصفيان هاني اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
مشهد الاجلاء وابرز مشاهداتك في هذه
الاوقات
نعم وصول دفعه جديده عبر طائره القوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه من نوع سي 1
فيرتي وهي طائره
قامت باجلاء اكثر من 150 شخصا من عده
جنسيات رعايه
لبلدان مختلفه طبعا هؤلاء قدموا من
بورسودان والى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه هنا في مدينه جده ووصلوا الى صله
الوصول طبعا الان هم في مراحلهم الاخيره
التي تم انهاء اجراءاتهم طبعا ابرز
المعوقات التي كانت تواجه المعظم في
الحقيقه هو عدم حمله لتاشيره كون الموضوع
هنا كحاله طارئه فقامت الجود او قامت
الحكومه السعوديه باستخراج تاشيرات
طارئه حتى يتم التمكن من دخولهم وبعد ذلك
السماح لهم بالوصول الى جده طبعا المعظم
تم
مخاطبه السفارات والقنصليات المعتمده
فمثلا الان في هذه الصوره نشاهد القنصل
التايلندي هنا في مدينه جده كان قد وصل
على هذه الرحله
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه اكثر من
35 شخصا من الجنسيه التايلنديه فلا بد من
حضور اعضاء السفاره او مندوبهم لانها
اجراءات ايضا رعياهم الذين وصلوا على هذه
الصاله ولا يختلف الامر كثيرا ايضا
بالنسبه من هم قدموا ايضا عبر الرحلات
البحريه سواء ممن كان على
متنه سفن القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
او ايضا ممن قدموا عبر الفرقاطات العسكريه
سواء الفرقاطه الصينيه او كذلك الفرنسيه
او ايضا الهنديه والتي وصلت الى مدينه جده
هنا الجزء الخارجي وهم ممن تم انهاء
اجراءاتهم ممن وصلوا لهذا اليوم والان يتم
توجههم نحو الحافلات وبعد ذلك يتم
نقلهم الى مقر اقامتهم داخل مدينه جده
هناك عدد من الفنادق من فئه من الفئات
العاليه تم تجهيزها لهم ويتم نقلهم وحتى
يتم انهاء اجراءاتهم النهائيه لمغادرتهم
الى بلدانهم او البعض يمكث لفتره معينه
حتى يتم انهاء اجراءاته اليوم بالنسبه
لتحديات والصعوبات التي تواجه معظم من
كانوا او ابرز الرعايه الذين واجهوا
الصعوبات والتحديات في وصولهم الى جده هي
الاعداد الكبيره التي الان هي تقف في
بورتسودان خاصه ممن لم يستطيعوا الوصول
الى مدينه جده ولم يستطيع اجلاؤهم
قله الطيران وقله السفن بالنسبه للدول
الاخرى معظم الدول التي وصلت الى مدينه
جده من الفرقاطات العسكريه او كذلك السفن
التجاريه هي فقط تحمل رايها باستثناء فقط
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه والقوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه التي كانت تحمل
معظم الرايه يبدو ايضا من حال حديث حديثنا
مع هؤلاء الرايه ان الوضع في بورت سودان
الازدحامه الشديد وكثره الاعداد من جنسيات
مختلفه هي سوف تسبب وتؤرق امرا كارثيا
انسانيا بحسب ما وصفوه لنا خاصه ان هناك
اعداد ايضا هذا امر يدفعنا الى ان هؤلاء
الاشخاص او هؤلاء هذه الجنسيات التي وصلت
اليوم كانت في بورسودان منذ سبعه ايام او
ثمانيه ايام منهم من مضى عليه اكثر من
اسبوع حتى استطاع الوصول الى هنا وحتى
استطاع ايضا التواصل مع سفارته خارج
السودان وكانت اقرب سفاره لهم او ممن تم
تحويله الى السفاره السعوديه او القنصليه
القنصليه بلاده في السعوديه
هاني عندما تتحدث اليهم يعني هل يعطوك
معلومات مثلا اذا كان هنالك كثير من الناس
ما زالوا عالقين ويريدون المغادره
وينتظرون دورهم يعني فقط حقيقه ما يجري
هناك هل يتحدث هؤلاء ايضا عن عمليات سلب
ونهب نسمع عنها كثيرا في الاعلام شاهدنا
بعض الفيديوهات عن فقدان السلع الغذائيه
هذا الانطباعات هل يمكن لمسها من خلال
اجوبه من تلتقيهم
المعظم ممن كان في الخرطوم فهو يحكي ماسه
اخرى منهم لم يستطع بالفعل ان يتحدث لنا
وحولت ان اخذ معه في كثره السؤال ماذا
يحدث في الخرطوم المعظم قال لا اريد ان
اتذكر البعض قال الخرطوم انتهت معظم
المواطنين السودانيين ايضا الذين تم
اجلاؤهم خاصه يوم امس من كبار السن قال
يعني ما زلنا في امل ان يعود السودان بخير
الجنسيات الاخرى بعضهم تعرضوا لاطلاق نار
فمثلا
السيد الذي امامنا وهو يحمل الجنسيه
الفلسطينيه كنا نحاول ان نتحدث معه
ونحاولوا لكن الرفض التعليق ولكن لعل هذه
المره الثانيه الذي احاول ان اسالك كيف هو
الوضع في السودان
والله يا اخي الكريم الوضع مزري والله
يعين الناس
شاهدته كنت تقص علي على حديث جانبي نريد
ان المشاهد يسمع
يعني عندك المعلومات كلها انه كان في
مقدمات الازمه والعائله اخر الكلام بعدين
فجاه انفجر الوضع
والناس والله تعبانه جدا جدا
شكرا لك شكرا اذا ما زال يخفي الكثير
السيد محمد هو من من الاشخاص الذين كانوا
يزوروا السودان في فتره طويله
انفصلوا عن انفصلت عائلته عن
نجا بنفسه وتبقى بعض ابنائي هناك لا يعلم
عنهم
البعض الاخر هو وصل الى جده بامان ما زال
هو قلق ولكن كان يتحدث اليه عن مشاهدته
للرصاص المنطقه التي كان يقطن فيها في
السودان منطقه خطيره جدا لم يستطيع الخروج
ظل قرابه سبعه ايام او اربعه ايام في
منزله لم يستطع الخروج منها الا بواسطه
تدخل احد اعضاء القنصليه الماليزيه هناك
فخرج سالما واليوم وصل الى جده هذا هو
حديثه طبعا هو رفض تماما حاولت ان يتحدث
معاه بشكل اكثر على الشاشه
الامر كان يسير قبل قليل وتحدث الينا
بكلمتين ولكن هذا هو الحال معظم الذين
وصلوا البعض الاخر في الحقيقه من مناطق
اخرى خارج الخرطوم فكان الامر صعب عليهم
فقط في الوصول الى بورت سودان حتى يتم
اجلؤهم الى
بلادهم او كذلك الى السعوديه على الاقل
تقدير طيب لاختم معك هاني في هذه
التغطيه لنذكر اي رحلات مجدوله رحلات
سعوديه مجدوله
اليوم او في الايام
المقبله يعني القاعده الجويه في جده كم
ستستقبل في الساعات المقبله من عمليات
اجلاء اذا كان لديك معلومات بالارقام
نعم بشكل نعم سوف اكون معك بشكل سريع سوف
نتحدث لدينا ثلاث مواقع تستقبل فيها
السعوديه
عمليات الاجلاء نتحدث عن قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ونتحدث عن ميناء جده الاسلامي
ونتحدث عن قاعده الملك عبدالله الجويه
التي نتواجد فيها ساتحدث معك في بدايه
الوتيره وبدايه الازمه في عمليات الاجلاء
كانت على سفينه سفينتين رحله رحلتين
جويتين اليوم ازداد هذا العدد لتصبح يوميا
اكثر من اربع رحلات جويه وكذلك وصول اكثر
من خمس سفن يوميه اليوم سوف تصل اليوم
وصلت صباحا سفينه لجلاله الملك الطائف وهي
تبع القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وفي
المساء سوف تصل ايضا سفينتين اخريتين
وايضا وصلت اليوم في ميناء جده الاسلامي
في فتره متزامنه ثلاث فرقاطات عسكريه
اثنتين سفينت
وسفينه هنديه كانت تحمل جميعهم الف شخص من
الرعايه الهند والصين اذا العمليه ازدادت
ونتوقع ايضا ان تزداد عدد عمليات الاجلاء
خلال الفتره المقبله اذا ما كان بالفعل ما
نقله الرعايه وشود عيان من الوضع الانساني
الذي يحدث في السودان وتحديدا في ازمه
العالقين في بورسودا من قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه بجده مراسل العربي هاني شكرا
جزيلا لك هاني على كل هذه المتابعه
اذا كنا نتحدث عن عمليات الاجلاء للرعايه
الاجانب من السودان فما مصير السودانيين
مع استمرار المواجهات وتردي الاوضاع
الامنيه
فاذا تستمر حركات النزوح الداخلي الى
مناطق بعيده عن مواقع الاشتباكات او الى
دول الجوار حيث يستمر الابلاغ عن نزوح
المدنيين في ولايات الخرطوم والولايه
الشماليه والنيل الازرق وشمال كردفان
وشمال دارفور وغرب دارفور وجنوب دارفور
الى جانب التحركات عبر الحدود الى البلدان
المجاوره
وقد حذرت الامم المتحده من ان ربع مليون
سوداني كما ذكرنا قد يكونون في طريقهم
الهرب برا الى الدول المجاوره ومن بين
الدول السبعه المجاوره للسودان فان اهم
التحركات وفق مفوضيه اللاجئين هي نحو تشاد
وجنوب السودان
المفوضيه اوضحت ايضا ان الذين شقوا طريقهم
بانفسهم الى المناطق الحدوديه مع تشاد
يقدر عددهم بنحو 20 الف شخص كما انها
تتوقع عبور نحو 45 الف لاجئ سوداني جديد
الى جنوب السودان والى مصر الجاره
الشماليه فقد ذكرت المفوضيه ان لديها
تقارير عن بدء خروج بعض النازحين الى مصر
في حين اعلنت السلطات المصريه ان الاف
الاشخاص من مختلف الجنسيات تمكنوا من
الخروج من السودان الى مصر عبر معبره قسطل
وارجيه حيث يتجاوز عددهم العشره الاف شخص
كما ترون انه مسجد بدايه السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان في جربه من
قوه الانفجار و
جينا السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبي يوقف
الحرب نسبه لدعم الشعبي وللمعاناه التي
عانها الشعب السوداني
اما في بورسودان فيستمر توافد مئات رعايه
مختلف الجنسيات من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم الشرقا وذلك بغرض استكمال اجراءات
اجلائهم خارج البلاد حيث ادى ذلك الاقتضاض
المئات من طالب اللجوء داخل مركز تنسيق
اجراءات المغادره بمدينه بورسودان كما
تعمل لجان الاشراف السودانيه بالتنسيق مع
سفارات الدول الاجنبيه على جمع وحصر
المغادرين والتاكد من بياناته وصلنا
بصعوبه صعوبه لا يعني ما توصف يعني قاعد
نمشي على القتله وصلنا هنا لكن ما في يعني
عشره يوم مرت علينا يمكن اكلين عيشه وحده
الاف او عشان ما يكون في مبالغه مئات من
السوريين موجودين في الخرطوم ما قادرين
يتحركوا اولا انعدام الامان ثانيا الغلاء
الموجود في بالنسبه للترحيل ثالثا
زي ما قلنا الشوارع ما كلها امنه يعني
بتساعد الناس لكن
نطلب رجاء خاص من برهان من حمدته الله
يهديكم ربنا يهديكم يعني الشعب السوداني
منتهي شعب السوداني في شارع الجاليات في
الشارع الناس يعني يعني ما ممكن نفرين
يتشاكلوا يضيعوا الناس في النص
وفي الاردن اجل الطائرات تابعه لسلاح الجو
الملكي الاردني سبعين شخصا من المواطنين
وجنسيات عربيه واجنبيه من الهيئات
الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الدوليه واكد
الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه سنان
المجالي ان عمان ستستمر بتقديم يد العون
للدول الصديقه وللرعايه الاردنيين في
السودان ممن لديهم الرغبه في الخروج من
الاراضي السودانيه يعني رحله كانت بر من
الخرطوم
عبر الامم المتحده اخذت تقريبا اربعين
ساعه بس الحمد لله انه يعني المملكه
الاردنيه يعني المبادره اللي عملوها
بيشكروا عليها رحلتي من السودان من داخل
السودان صراحه كان في كثير مخاطر تعرضنا
لها لكن الحمد لله تيسرت والله كان الوضع
كتير صعب صعب كتير كتير يعني
فجاه صارت المشاكل وضرب ويعني قطعه
الكهرباء والمي
وعلينا كتير
وقف انا ناس مواطنين مسالمين دارين ياكلوا
لقمه الايش نمشي وين المشكله بقى خطير
علينا
[موسيقى]
الناس
المساجين
اليوم باليوم وانت يا النفرين انا الدائري
منكم بس تهزوا
تستفوا
وعلى الحدود بين مصر والسودان اصبح معبر
وارجين البريه الفاصل بين البلدين بمثابه
طوق نجاه الفري من الاشتباكات حيث عبر من
خلاله ما لا يقل عن عشره الاف شخص خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتح سبتمبر عام 2016 لنقل
البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850 كيلو
مترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من 300 شاحنه
بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من اشتباكات
السودان عبر منه الالاف من السودانيين
والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد اجتياز
المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه اسوان
الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه بالمتاعب
تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من الخرطوم
ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان ونظرا
لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح للسودانيين
بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
بعد النزوح اعزائي المشاهدين تظلوا لحظات
الرعب عالقه في الاذهان هذا هو حال وعائله
سودانيه هربت من النزاع الى مصر كاميرا
العربيه وثقت لحظات خوف عاشتها اسره
سودانيه تحت عزيزه الرصاص
ان تعود الى منزلك مطمئنا انك ستجد اسرتك
في امان هذا يساوي الكثير عند عبد اللطيف
حامد المقيم في مصر منذ سنوات بعد ان كاد
القلق يفتك به خوفا على اسرته التي كانت
تحاول الهروب من الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان ووصلت بسلام الى مصر منذ ثلاثه
ايام انا كنت جالك جدا وكنت متابعا
بالتليفون عبر التلفونات وعبر الواتساب
لحظه انه الاتصال اتقطع بيني وبينه بكون
دايما خايف وعايش في رعب شديد انه البلد
ما امنه يعني حتى لحد الحمد لله لحد ما
وصلوا اسطوان وكنت متابعهم خطوه بخطوه
وكلمه بكلمه قرار الخروج من كسلا ومن
السودان صوب مصر اتخذته السيده سوسن
وابنتها ريما خوفا على اولادهما قبل الحرب
كانت صعبه وهسه زاد الوضع سوق عندنا العيش
في المخابز ما في الغاز ما في كهرباء ما
في مويه ما في يعني الحياه انعدمت تماما
يعني في اي لحظه نحن ممكن نضيعوا مني اما
الرحله الطويله التي استغرقت ثلاثه ايام
فكانت خليطه من المشقه والخوف
خفيفه الاولاد عايزين
ياكلوا عايزين يشربوا عايزين يناموا
مرتاحين فهمته وبعدين صوت النار العلب
يخافوا في الايام العاديه غير الحرب كان
في نهر
يعني انت بتيجي ماشي بالعربيه فين في في
ناس بيموت وكده في الطريق يعني هسه احنا
لما جاي قلبنا في يدنا في المرعب
يعني
في الشوارع الرصاص
والحريق لا نحن محتاجين دكتور نفساني
والله العظيم يعني يعني
الوضع من جوه
يعني مستحيل انك تشوف يعني انت في لحظه
وانت قاعد في بيتك مطمئن فجاه تلقى نفسك
بقيت اخيرا تم لم شمل الاسره بعد عناء
تركوه وراء ظهورهم مع ما تركوه من امتعه
في بيتهم المغلق في كسلا فهم جاؤوا باقل
القليل من الملابس ويشعرون بعدم الثقه في
ان مهنتهم ستنتهي قريبا تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
وفي اعقاب مبادره منظمه اليجاد نفت
الخارجيه السودانيه الانباء التي تتحدث عن
تفاوض الجيش مع الدعم السريع مشيره الى ان
لا صحه لقبول الجيش بالتفاوض مع الدعم
السريع والا خيار امام الدعم السريع سوى
الاستسلام واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه ان
قوات الدعم السريع مستمره في خروقاتها
للهدنه وتعديها على المدنيين واستخدامهم
كدروع بشريه بيان الخارجيه السودانيه
اتهمت دعم السريع بالاعتداء على
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
وتعطيل عملها
اعود الى من قطع من اتصال من الخرطوم مع
السيد مصباح احمد وهو رئيس دائره الاعلام
في حزب الامه القومي والقياديه في حل
الحريه والتغيير سيد مصباح اهلا وسهلا بك
مجددا ارجو ان تكون تسمعني الان لانه
الاتصال يتقطع هل توضح فعليا وبشكل جليم
موقف الجيش والفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان من
مبادره الايجاد لانه الان الخارجيه
السودانيه تنفي نفيا قاطعا عن اي امكانيه
تفاوض بين الجيش والدعم السريع وتقول ان
لا خيار امام الدعم السريع سوى الاستسلام
بالامس كانت المعلومات متضاربه او متواتره
تقول انه لا الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
وافق على مبادره الايجاد وهو مستعد للجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات مع الجنرال احمد يعني
وكل هذا الكلام ما حقيقه كل ما يجري
شكرا جزيلا شكرا لقناه العربيه الحقيقه ان
هنالك بيانات متضاربه تصدر من الخارجيه
ومن القوات المسلحه البيانات صاد من
القوات المسلحه اكد على ان السيد البرهان
يستقبل مبادره من الايجاد وابدا موافقه
مبدئيه
ومن قبل ايضا السيد البرهان نفسه تحدث عبر
قناتكم وذكر انه مستعد للحوار وان اي
عمليه يجب ان تنتهي بالحوار اعتقد ان
البيان الخارجيه
ليس دقيقه
كبيان القوات المسلحه في تقديري ان
الطرفين الان هما لديهما رغبه في التفاوض
ولكن كل منهما يحاول ان يحسن شروط هذا
التوافق وتفاوض على الارض او يحاول ان
يكسب اراضي على الارض حتى يستطيع ان
يتفاوض وهو في وضع مريح هذا هذا
ولكن في تقديره لا يمكن من البرهان ان
يرفض
الحوار حسب ما اعلم هو نفسه كذلك ايضا
الطرف الاخر فوائد الدعم السريع ايضا اعلن
انه مستعد لهذه لهذه لهذه الحوار اذا
وتوفرت شروط معينه وكذلك من ناحيه
المبادره اعتقد به المبادره لم تصل حتى
الان بصوره مفصله سواء اقترحت نقاط عناوين
وقف التمديد الهدنه الى 72 ساعه ثم
تطويرها الى وقت الحرب ومن ثم جلوس طرفين
من
او ممثلين من الطرفين لدراسه المبادره
والنقاش حولها ومن ثم يعودان لقيادتهم
لاتخاذ
المواقف ولكن اعتقد بالنسبه لنا على الاقل
نحن في القوى المدنيه وما نبذله من جهود
في تقديرنا انه حسب ما لم يسناه من
الطرفين انهما يرقبان في الحوار ولكن كل
منهما يحاول ان يناور في هذه المرحله وان
يحسن وضعه في الميدان حتى يستطيع ان
يتحاور بشكل مريح القوه المدنيه ايضا
تمارس ضغوط عديده على الطرفين والمجتمع
الدولي بتيسير مع مجتمع الدولي من اجل وقف
هذه الحرب الان المدنيه جديده على الساحه
السياسيه تضغط باتجاه وقف هذه الحرب
الاوضاع المتدنيه والمترديه ايضا تضغط على
الطرفين بضروره قبول عمليه التفاوض وكذلك
تفجر الاوضاع الان في بعض المناطق في
ولايه السودان مختلفه لكن
الصراع تحول من صراع عسكري ما بين الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه الى صراع فيه تحول
الى حرب اهليه وهذا مؤسف للايه ايضا سيكون
له تاسيس على الطرفين ولابد ان يقبلها
بالحوار حتى يستطيعان كذلك الامر طيب هو
اليوم الثالث عشر من المعارك والاقتتال هل
تعتقد ان الهدنه الهشه برغم هشاشتها
ستظل ساريه وسيتم تمديدها ام لا انتم غير
متفائلون بذلك غير متفائلين بذلك سيد
مصباح
نعم الهدنه بالرغم من انه هذه الهدنه
الرابعه هي الافضل من بين الهدن السابقه
باعتبار انها يعني شهدت هدوء نسبيا في بعض
الاحياء العاصمه الخرطوم حاصل المسلسه
وقلت اصوات الاشتباكات المباشره ما بين
الطرفين في بعض المناطق سوى المناطق
المنتزه انا اسف للمقاطعه اعزائي
المشاهدين انتقل بكم مباشره الى البرلمان
البريطاني وكلمه لوزير الخارجيه البريطاني
جيمس كليبرلي حول الاوضاع في السودان نبحث
في كافه السبل للقيام بذلك دون تعريض
مواطنين للخطر
السيد الرئيس ان وقفه لقناه ليس مقدمه
بالضروره للسلام والوضع يمكن ان يتفاقم في
الايام المقبله سنواصل دعم الرعايه
البريطاني لذلك قمنا بانشاء تواجد في
بورتسودان ولدينا مسؤولين دبلوماسيون في
مصر واثيوبيا والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
السيد الرئيس السودان هو ثالث اكبر بلد
افريقي
ويبعد حول 800 ميل من بين العاصمه واسوان
في مصر وخمسمائه بين الخرطوم والبحر
الاحمر حتى في ظل انعدام
الحرب فان هناك الكثير من التحديات ندرك
الكثير من الرعايه البريطانيين غادروا
السودان بوسائل اخرى بعضهم استطاعوا ان
يستفيدوا من اجلاء الذي تقوم به دول شريكه
نحن نعمل على مهامنا الدبلوماسيه
لتقديم المساعدات القنصليه السيد الرئيس
نقوم ببذل كل الجهود لاجلاء رعينا وسلام
في السودان هو هدف اساسي ندعو الجانبين
لوقفه قتل لمصلحه سوداني لدى عنه ما يكفي
خلال عقود من الحرب الاهليه نبحث كل السبل
لخفض الصعيد وزير الدفاع وزير التنميه
هو ان على اتصال مباشر مع شركائنا
الدوليين دور الاتحاد الافريقي وكذلك
منظمات وشركائنا في المنطقه والخليج
وخارجها سيكون حاسما السيد الرئيس المملكه
المتحده لديها علاقات تعميقه مع الشعب
السوداني نحن تضامن معه وندعم حقه في
الحصول على المستقبل ديمقراطي وللعوده الى
الحكم المدني المملكه المتحده
مستعده لدعم الجهود دوليه لاعاده بناء
الاقتصاد السوداني ووقف معناه لكن المهمه
ليست سهله غير انها حيويه
للاقليم
والسوداني سنواصل القيام بذلك وسنجلي
رعايهنا لاماكن امنه وسنعمل ايضا على
اعاده اعمار هذا البلد العظيم شكرا لكم
كنا مع جيمس كليفر لوزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه في البرلمان البريطانيه متحدثا
عن الازمه في السودان قال المدير الاقليمي
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه لشرق المتوسط
الدكتور احمد المنظري ان الهجمات على
البنيه التحتيه الصحيه في السودان تتصاعد
مع سيطره اطراف النزاع على المستشفيات في
الخرطوم وناشد المنظر عبر تغريده الله على
تويتر اطراف النزاع الاخلاء الفوري لجميع
المرافق الصحيه وعدم اعاقه وظائف الصحه
العامه الحيويه
اممي من كارثه صحيه في السودان 24 الف
امراه سيلدن دون رعايه صحيه 50 الف طفل
يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
احدى وستون في المئه من المنشات الصحيه
مغلقه
16% من المرافق الصحيه تمارس عملها
المراكز المخصصه لمنع تفشي الاوبئه توقفت
عن العمل مع امكانيه وقوع اصابات بسبب شرب
مياه غير صالحه
هجمه على مراكز المنظمه الطبيه ومقتل
ثمانيه اشخاص
الاستيلاء على مختبر طبي يثير مخاوف من
مخاطر بيولوجيه والتلاعب بالعينات
المخزونه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات